we got this really crazy story about uh
this guy named The Merchant of death an
arms dealer who was released um uh in
this trade in exchange and I guess he
he's claiming he sent a message to
Donald Trump that I'll keep it very
light the Biden Administration would
prefer to make it so that he's no longer
alive before they let him get in their
way you know I'm being very very
delicate with the description of this
story and so we're going to talk about
that because that's going to lead us
into a lot of conversations around Ford
intervention War economic policy and uh
some cultural issues there's some I
don't know some weird actor guys Luke he
was a weird actor he was talking about
actor musician talking about
Exterminating Republicans so all of this
talk that we've seen is actually quite
worrying and then there's this crazy
story about one of the Democrats who was
expelled in Tennessee who uh well
there's a video of him from a few years
ago where he's a middle of the road
Centrist and then when you look at
videos of him today he's doing this
preacher bit and everyone's saying he's
basically grifting it's either that or
or we have completely hyper polarized
rapidly and with talk of you know people
saying things like exterminate
Republicans yeah maybe things are
getting just a little bit hyper
polarized before we get started my
friends head over to
castbrewcoffee.com this is our coffee
brand that we launched and I guess it
doesn't appear on the screen properly
but it doesn't matter and uh check it
out if you can pre-order yours today
we've officially launched it's in
production and you can pick up my
favorite rise with Roberto Jr
uh breakfast blend it's a light roast
and plus our Appalachian nights and
we've got more products coming but for
the time being this is uh just
preliminary we're sponsoring ourselves
we don't want to get canceled then we
want to start building companies so of
course we're putting together a uh
coffee shop as well as as Sonic coffee
and head over to timcast.com click join
us to become a member because we're
gonna have a members only uncensored
show coming up for you tonight at about
10 10 p.m eastern time and for those
that have been members for at least six
months or those who joined at the 25 per
month level you get instant access to
our VIP voice chat it's basically a
screening process and then you can
submit questions and even call into the
show and yes we have it working tonight
so you can call in ask us questions and
I think this one is going to be a very
special episode so smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends and share it
right now because this one is going to
be one for the ages because joining us
tonight is the legendary Dr Ron Paul
very nice nice to be with you today uh
it is an absolute honor I've been uh
following you for maybe half my life I
remember back in 2008 you lit a fire
under so many young people with the talk
of Freedom anti-intervention sound
Economic Policy I had friends who were
making music videos based off your ideas
that were conveying similar messages and
arguing on the internet so uh it
absolutely is an honor especially
considering any everything that's going
on right now would you like to just
introduce yourself for everybody well
it's an issue that has caught my
attention a long time ago because I came
across this school of thought and
economics called the Austrian School of
economics and it fascinated me I was
practicing medicine I was studying
medicine and I was a resident and going
through there but that was my hobby was
trying to understand how the economic
system worked and uh and I found out in
the 1960s there were a lot of people who
were predicting you know this idiocy of
the woods agreement the pseudo gold
standard that was set up at the end of
World War II even back then Henry Hazard
said it's stupid it don't do it it
doesn't work and so the predictions were
going and the the the black market the
real market of gold it was thick the dog
the dollar was fixed at 35 an ounce that
was official but we had most of the gold
so we had license to steal by just
printing money and handing out the money
and that uh that that made it easy for
the predictions it's not going to last
we can see it it's sort of like today
we're talking about when's the dollar
going to end well back then it was when
was the dollar going to be an honest
currency and uh and and and and be
backed by gold where they had already uh
declared bankruptcy in 1934 because they
stole all the gold but Roosevelt stole
all the gold from the American people
and uh so that was a bankruptcy they
they promised they'd always give us 35
dollars for paper and the amazing thing
is people said oh okay that's fine just
so I can get my good goodies and the
money Works to a degree so they patch
that together but they never they never
gave the gold back to the people and uh
that that is what led me into it and
when the crash of the dollar came in
1971 is when I thought I want to speak
out on it and a vehicle was the
political system and then you ended up
how many terms did you serve in Congress
I'd have to go and count them again
about 23 years but I was in three
different times yeah you know so it uh
it led to more but I I really I had no
desire I never had a goal of you know
this is a good deal I think I have an
opportunity I think I could become a
congressman never once did that ever
cross my mind because I remember so
clearly when I talked to my wife and I
was at a very nice medical practice and
loved medicine loved delivering babies
that might seem strange but I did I love
delivering babies and so when I told her
she said what in the world would you do
that for and I said I tried to explain
to her what I just said you know it's an
important issue and that's sort of
something I've looked after and I want
to speak out she said you shouldn't do
it it's very dangerous and she was not
into conspiracy she didn't know anything
about that stuff but she said it was
dangerous and it turned out that she was
right because she says it's dangerous
because you're going to probably get
elected and and mix up our lives and so
I didn't expect to I thought it was just
a speaking opportunity and that's the
way it was for a long time I was there
for six years and decided I wanted to go
back to medicine I've still had kids to
go through college and then as time went
on and the conditions didn't get much
better so I ran for congress again you
know in 1995 and went back back into the
Congress but uh but she was right and I
was wrong and and even the people who
suggest said oh yeah I got interested in
what you were talking about you know
when you ran for president in 2007 and
2008 and 2012 and believe me I I didn't
I didn't anticipate that there would be
people like maybe in this room that
thought well you know that sounds
interesting stuff you know and so I was
fascinated about wow and then I had this
uh Revelation that when I went to the
college campuses that young people were
more open-minded when with than old
people I decided Chamber of Commerce is
weren't offering Us free enterprise so
the young people were responding very
well matter of fact the one the one
event that I remember so clearly was
when we went to Berkeley I think I think
Berkeley was considered liberal wasn't
it that's the way that was a little bad
liberal but that was my biggest crowd I
had eight thousand young people come out
and I thought there's something it
because I knew I wasn't that great a
speaker so I I said that is a great
message you know what people want to
know and young people want to know and I
would emphasize that this is what you're
getting into and so I changed my
attitude no not every young person in
college in Liberal College are all of a
sudden going to have uh you know great
wisdom but there was a group there that
was uh you know open-minded enough that
if they heard something if it was
interesting that they would grab hold of
it and so since that time I would say
that I have been impressed with uh the
interest that has been shown and that to
me is the most important thing Minds
have to be changed and that's what I
hope I can contribute to you've
certainly done it for I think everybody
here so thank you for joining us and
there's so there's a million one
questions I already have but we'll we'll
get we'll introduce the other guests
well we got Daniel McAdams joining us
hey Tim thanks for having me on uh yeah
do you want to introduce yourself to
everybody yeah I went to work for Dr
Paul in 2001 I was living in Central
Europe Europe as the US was about to
bomb Yugoslavia and I noticed that
there's one great congressman who said
this is the stupidest idea ever what the
heck are we doing bombing Yugoslavia for
and I had spent some time down there and
I knew that this was the stupidest thing
so when I finally got back to DC just by
luck I guess
um I found there's one person I didn't I
never set out to work in Congress at all
but I wanted to work for this person who
was who got it and so I was very very
fortunate to have started working for
him in 2001 and we went all the way
through his last time in Congress and we
started the Ron Paul Institute in 2013.
so we this is our 10th year our 10th
anniversary as a Ron Paul Institute we
focus on foreign policy and civil
liberties almost exclusively sounds
great awesome thanks for joining us
Ian's sitting right next to uh Daniel
over here hi everyone great to be here
good to see you Ron Daniel great to meet
you man and you guys brought up uh the
restrict act and actually mentioned
something that I've been talking about
calling it The Patriot Act 2.0 yeah
thank you that was great that was it you
nailed it thank you sir anyway we also
have lucrid Caskey yep everyone in the
chat room is saying and the FED which is
pretty awesome my name is Luke adamski
of we are change.org I'm really excited
to ask Ron about his time machine uh
we're gonna find about that plus a lot
more on the show the shirt that I'm
wearing right now says I identify as a
conspiracy theorist my pronouns are told
you so which you could get on the
bestpoliticalshirts.com and I'm doing uh
in real life Meetup this Thursday 3 30
p.m in Austin find out more about that
on lucanfilter.com Ron doctor no thank
you so much for coming doctor no well
let's jump into this first story which
will kick things off we have this from
timcast.com and it says Victor bout
warns Trump of assassination threat from
the Biden Administration quote they
would sooner end your life than let you
stand in their way okay now I'll just
stress The Merchant of death as they
call him claiming that the bite
Administration is even considering this
is just hearsay coming from a guy who is
an arms dealer who is Russian so I'm not
saying which necessarily trust him I
just think the general idea is
interesting that this guy is basically
calling on Trump here's what he said
quote therefore I think it's in the
interest of all of humanity and
primarily of the American people to
invite Donald Trump here to Russia to
give him security and protection here so
that he leads this Uprising against the
globalists and most importantly does not
allow the elimination of the American
people
I just think it's a particularly bold
and I don't know kind of creepy story as
it were but I do think that in this vein
we are we are staring at the potential
for world war three if if we're not
already in it Russia wants to put
nuclear weapons in Belarus the U.S is
providing arms intelligence and you know
I'll say this they're indirectly the
United States indirectly has individuals
on the ground volunteers who are
fighting the Russians I think that
whether or not his sentiment is correct
we are facing some kind of very serious
International conflict so I'm curious Dr
Paul your thoughts on everything that's
been going on with that well I have made
up my mind whether or not when people
talk about World War III and most people
uh think in their mind about World War
one and World War II is a certain type
of war tanks and bombs and airplanes and
all that and I can't quite visualize
that I think the world has changed too
much and matter of fact politics has
changed a whole lot as well but I I've
concentrated more recently on thinking
about how to how do revolutions come
about have their changes been made have
we had a World War III to do it and I'm
arguing the case that uh we're in the
middle of it and moving right along that
that the revolution has been fought and
it is uh you know there's been a coup
that take a we don't have any
resemblance uh to a government that
believes in a republic we don't have
honest money we don't have integrity we
don't even have people in Washington
that even pretends you know that you're
supposed to tell the truth you know
remembers just recently there was a
congressperson that won and he he won by
putting on his resume just a bunch of
lies and and the other one's got
hysterical the other Congress was
telling lies like this and I got to
thinking well how many of these people
that were complained about this guy
telling lies how many of them lied when
they raised their hand up and swerved
uphold the Constitution now that's a lie
that really has consequences actually
you could probably make fun and make a
little joke because his jokes weren't
everybody knew he was fibbing but uh the
Real Lies are being told and that is our
big problem but I do believe there has
been a coup and it's been taken over and
if I want to if I can I want to just put
the date in my mind and you anybody
could pick probably any date in the last
Hunter a year but I've picked uh I have
picked November 22nd 1963. what happened
on that day that was the day Kennedy was
murdered by our government wow you know
by the CIA and at the time I remember I
was in a matter of fact Kennedy uh was
killed in uh in in Dallas but he landed
at Kelly Air Force Base and I was a
flight surgeon there the day before and
I was aware of this TR of this trip so
this was this was a a big a big thing
and those early years which we talked
about a lot especially the first year or
two oh Roswell did it Oswald did it and
then and you know the person they they
talk about most is uh uh it's uh
Alan Dulles as being the instigator of
all this and he uh guess what to LBJ and
immediately saying we have to
investigate this this president has been
assassinated what what they never use
the word coup so he's been assassinated
so I I guess he puts there were seven on
the commission and uh and uh dollars you
know Dallas was put on the committee to
investigate it so but he was going to
make sure they told the truth it was a
big Force but that was a big day in
history in my mind yeah that was the
beginning of the Hostile takeover of the
American government by the spy agencies
that of course have been becoming more
powerful less unaccountable by every
decade they've been doing more crazier
things and then we came to Iran Contra
they've been getting away with so many
crazy things they'd never never been
held accountable and for every decade
it's like oh yes the last decade the CIA
did something really horrible that but
they but they were never held
accountable for it but they're
definitely not doing it now but well
they are but I I thought you were going
to say 1913.
well I think that was the groundwork I I
start the uh intellectual change is a
little bit before 1913 probably at the
turn of the century uh you know the
Roosevelt era and the university started
teaching progressivism and gradually
they destroyed the whole principle of uh
like today in medicine there's no such
thing as truth anymore and this is this
Society has become nihilistic because
they can do anything they want and they
have a zero guilt they have no shame
because uh they don't believe they don't
believe there is such a thing as true
and uh even both religious and
non-religious people sort of come around
to agreeing you know a society would do
better if one if they had one rule don't
don't commit violence against anybody
else you know when it isn't that
complicated it's basically the
Constitution goes along with that but
not many people take that seriously and
but no I think 1913 was a consequence of
what was happening in the universities
and the universities are still in bad
shape but the real education that is
going on now is continuing especially in
economics and and other things I mean
there's there's a Institute now dealing
only with non-intervention and foreign
policy you take a group like The mises
Institute they've done a world of good
at teaching young people and I still
rely on them to understand uh you know
free market economics so that is where
the real change is and uh you know I
have I'm a fan of homeschooling and
homeschooling can be a Salvation too and
I happen to have a little program for
that but that the private schools we
still they're still legal in the 1980s
early 1980s there was such an effort to
close down every private school
conceivable in you know the record cases
that in spite of how bad things were
they recovered from that and but that
doesn't make me complacent to think they
won't touch us again in private
education because they will because when
they see that that the people who
telling the truth of the real enemies
and that's what's going on in politics
can I I'm curious your thoughts on
Donald Trump as a candidate as a
president
is he running again yeah
well I don't I don't think a lot about
it uh I I think politicians are pretty
much irrelevant
you know uh they're they they reflect
what's going on and uh but I I think the
least important thing well I can't say
that every single thing I did was not
related to politics because I
concentrated on one philosophic issue
and maybe made a little impression and
that was uh what sound money is all
about and uh talking about art the FED
prior to 1976 when I first went to
Washington the Federal Reserve was never
talked about and they thought boy people
would come up to me and what do you what
are you talking about them for you know
they'd be wonderful so I think that uh
but I really do believe that the
politicians just reflect a prevailing
attitude of the opinions of the people
very very important so what I saw is
dramatic and wonderful was during the
lockdowns that when crowds finally said
enough is enough and they started to
rebel against that stuff so it wasn't it
wasn't a dictatorship of the majority in
a political sense it was the people got
disgusted and they woke up and you had
Parents waking up but they're ruining
our kids you know and they were they
would go to parent PTA meetings and fire
some of those people so I think attitude
is a very important education is very
important so that's why right now I
probably spend
90 percent of my time trying to
understand and pass a message on to
others the reason why I asked about
Trump is because you said just a moment
ago that you think the change the
Revolution was nine was it 1963 I think
you said 63. oh no the the beginning the
coup that was 62. 62 sorry I got the
wrong uh I'm you know based this the
story we pulled up and you have this
Russian arms dealer saying Trump's at
risk I'm wondering if you think there's
any uh validity to that what was that
again the Russian arms dealer claiming
that Trump's life is at risk because
he's trying to stop globalists I'm
wondering if you think that's absurd uh
well to me that come across with that is
I probably don't know enough about it to
be really astute about it but it seems
so superficial you know I'm more into
Marxism and why marxists are nihilists
and why the the whether the the original
marxists or the culture marxists of
today that their main goal since they
don't have to worry about truth and
honesty their main goal is is chaos
Street chaos riots and you don't have to
go very far to to look around for what's
going on their goal is uh and so I I
still struggle with it why they do this
it's so stupid and so harmful the only
real explanation it isn't it isn't
stupidity it's done on purpose because
chaos leads to the breakdown of order
and uh that's that is our real real
threat but it originated I think back
even before 1913 it's just that then it
actually it was uh 1960
three I'd say that that assassination
was a big thing that same decade Martin
Luther King and RFK
and over a hundred people that were
loosely associated with Kennedy that
they they suddenly died nobody knows
exactly which ones were related or what
but there there's some noise out there
that uh really indicates that it was a
big big event wow Bobby Kennedy Malcolm
X as well I was I was wondering what do
you think about uh another Kennedy
running for the presidency and that's
Robert Kennedy Jr uh are you guys
excited about uh him potentially running
yeah because he announced we talk about
it it even though uh even though we we
don't promote legislation but we talk
about it and he's a friend and he came
out to one of one of our anti-war
conferences and people loved him and I
think I think it's great uh that he's
running but uh it's it's not likely I
mean I'd have him on my program if he
would come on but I I probably am not
into the endorsing business you know
because because I think it's very
secondary to waking up to people I want
the people to wake up about the monetary
issue which we're going to have the
opportunity because this monetary system
is just starting to crack and then the
people wake up just like they got sick
of uh sick and tired of the lockdown and
I told I talk about the football game
that I don't remember where it was but
there were a hundred thousand people
showed up and they didn't wear masks and
that was sort of the Breakthrough I
thought that was fantastic the people
will wake up and that's that's what I
figure that I can contribute to wake
people up do you if you uh I just want
to ask you to elaborate on the monetary
policy aspect right now we're seeing
eggs at six dollars for for a dozen
we're seeing uh you know uh Banks going
insolvent can you explain what this
economic system is what's wrong with it
well uh the the main reason is is you
don't have a definition of the unit of
account because if you were building a
building
and you were an architect you'd want a
unit of account or a unit of a
measurement uh how are we going to
measure all these things are we going to
do it in feet yards or whatever because
everything has to be measured in
economics you have to have a unit of
account and that of course is a defined
currency and they can get away with you
know we're messing it up for long
periods of time we were able to get away
with destroying the unit of account you
know all the way back in 1934 and 1971
the way it is now but we were very very
wealthy and we still are wealthy but
we're getting poorer because people rely
on debt and the debt is growing and uh
the the price inflation is moving along
and uh it's a consequence that they've
destroyed them one of the most important
items the most important price in
economics is the price of money how much
it takes to borrow what was it minus for
a couple years and during that time the
family come up and said oh oh you know
we're having trouble we we want we want
the inflation the price inflation we
want the destruction of the value of
money go at two percent a year and it's
down to minus one or minus two this is
the craziest thing in the world the last
the last thing they they should be doing
but now and I said you know when it
finally gets to two percent you wait you
won't even see it it'll be ten percent
after that and uh and and now that's
because there's the uh there's the
theory of subjective theory of value
that tells you that you can't make those
predictions but you can make predictions
that if you mess up with the uh monetary
system run up debt it all this debt has
to be liquidated and we are in the
middle of defaulting on that money and
that is going that is the crisis we face
and right now we're not very far along
at accepting what we have to accept if
we want to crawl our way out of here and
get back to being a productive Nation do
you think I just I just want to go back
a little bit but what you said before
this statement because I think this is
what really is important about your
message A lot of people are like what
politician is going to save me and in
reality no politician is going to save
you personal responsibility is extremely
important what's happening with the big
Banks what's happening with the ESG
score the international multinational
corporations running things is far more
important especially when it comes to
your own individual
decisions that you make in everyday life
and I think this is why that message is
so much more important because
everyone's like please someone save us
in reality the only person who's going
to save you is you yourself and and you
know you've taken many steps
homeschooling you opened up a
homeschooling Network as well can you
tell us how that is going and how people
could potentially be involved in that
well it's the Ron Paul Curriculum you
just get on the website there and the
school did has done it steady and does
well but there was a big big burst of
interest you know during covet but some
of the people went back to the
government schools you know after that
so uh I I think that uh peop people will
respond and that's why the important
thing is to keep things legal so that we
can do that and that's why the internet
is so important it can be be a destroyer
or it could be our savior I mean we do
our program you know on the Internet
it's where we do it we get a programs
like this out so that that is uh and
every once in a while I'll see something
I've always thought oh the Libertarians
will take care of that there's a lot of
smart people they know this and when the
government comes in and takes over the
Internet they will have competition and
I think we're getting it and uh and it's
just a little bit slow in doing it but I
I think as long as you have some Freedom
there and can use it but that's why
we're in such a threatening period
because they're destroying our first
amendment rights you know people are
getting punished for this they lose
their jobs I knew doctors that you know
I'm taking care of patients and they say
and they might have you know their
livelihood and they say well if you
don't get your shot you know you're
you're going to lose your hospital
position if uh your hospital
privileges that that is really wicked
stuff so that that protecting the first
amendment is one of our biggest uh
challenges right now yeah I think the
way the First Amendment translates to
the internet is software code we need
the access to our software code so we
can see if it's spying on us or if it's
feeding us Mal information algorithms
it's going to be like something an
amendment maybe to the Constitution to
well guarantee of Freedom let me let me
break that down and actually ask you Dr
Paul what uh Ian brings up a great point
when you're on Facebook when you're on
Twitter they're choosing what you see to
manipulate what you think so how can we
have free speech if these big
corporations are only letting us see see
one thing well you can't and I'll be the
first one to tell you the technology uh
I don't understand a lot of it but I
wanted to be free and to make make these
decisions elsewhere but uh no the big
thing is and uh you know Jonathan Turley
has done such a great job to exposing
this the line has to be drawn in and I
bet you there are a lot of Libertarians
at the beginning of this I always
thought well these companies are private
they can do what they want if we're not
going to close them down and but there
is an answer for that they're not
private and early on I said they're
nothing but the arm of the government
and uh and then and that's a big
difference and then all of a sudden we
got the proof of that but that came out
now not many people are talking about it
but the FBI and the CIA they work with
these uh these uh these companies like
all the social welfare so social
companies well that that is a that is a
big deal and that could be stopped
that's that should uh it should be uh
you know a a violent act to do that
especially when the government's here
that's why we should have
a lot less government yes and they did
it from the very beginning especially
with companies like nqutel especially
with a lot of the seed funding
especially with a lot of the advancement
that government gave companies like
Google alphabet to the advantage over
their competitors and I saw a lot of
people argue you know even just a couple
years ago being like these companies are
private companies they could do what
they want we have to stand by capitals
I'm like you guys aren't even paying
attention to what's really going on here
because as you said they are arms of the
state they are acting for their own best
interest and they're sowing division in
this country creating order out of chaos
to specifically create a situation where
we are fighting each other over Petty
differences rather than actually looking
at the true source of our problem and
that's the dollar being the valued
that's our currency just being thrown
away and our whole livelihoods just
being taken away from us which is
absolutely crazy do you think it would
be righteous to default on the interest
to the Federal Reserve
oh
uh yeah I think if I could write a pen
and close down the Federal Reserve I
just would and everybody has to scatter
what would what would be like the
evolution of our monetary system how
what's a better system but I wouldn't do
that I you know I I guess if I I say the
most important thing if you want to act
in a is a somewhat gradual system
because you're not going to do that
you're not going to do it because if you
cut the FED off uh the the whole thing
crashes and they'll be revolutions and
all this so uh I I I started with uh
getting more information that's why I
concentrate on auditing the FED find out
what they're doing and the one thing
over the many years that I've worked on
this that is the most uh important uh
information that they hang on to and
that is their transactions with foreign
governments that is that is really
sacred and uh they uh they don't want
that to happen I've been told that they
work with the bank for international
settlements in Switzerland and like the
bank of London the bank of Australia and
the New York Federal Reserve are like
they all send money through this Swiss
bank yeah that's right it's a bank for
the central banks and I guess they have
to park some of their money in places
but it's the nature of the monetary
system see if uh prior to uh Central
Banking which was uh you know the debate
started with our Revolution with
Jefferson and Hamilton you know there
was no they weren't discussing the bank
of international settlements back back
then so it's uh it's it's totally
unnecessary in a free market the most
important thing is Define the currency
by weight or something real and uh then
uh the the then prohibiting anybody from
disobeying it the Constitution is pretty
clear on it and to some of the states
now are reacting to this states are
coming through and trying to develop
their own own currency because it's
tough for them to say well you know the
state's uh states can only use uh you
know gold and silver as legal tender now
my bill in Congress was a little bit
more generalized it said repeal all the
laws all the monopoly laws that the
government has and control and let the
market decide it but if the founder said
no uh even the states can't just print
up their own money but I think in a free
Society a Libertarian Society you could
have contracts if you're setting up a
bank and you say this is the unit of
account and they say and you're going to
use gold you have to live up to your
contract it seems like crypto is the new
contract which is data like what's the
account symbol it's how much work was
done to produce the Bitcoin or whatever
so you can see on a on a database well
there's this much computer power used
well yeah and that gets a little more
complex because if you say uh what is
what's behind goal you know everybody
knows gold they've used it for five
thousand years so people know what what
it is but it's always been gold didn't
be didn't fall out of the sky and become
money goldfell came out of the ground
and was pretty
and they used it you know jewelry and it
valued and all the important things of
money that that happened then it became
very practical to be used as money but
you might find uh you might find 20
things and more all the time there's
there's actually things uh uh being
Advanced now even when I was in medical
school we studied about there was some
arthritis that uh that could be treated
with gold and silver gold especially and
there's more and more Silver's been used
as a medication and so it should be
legalized for that reason but that's
what helps make it money that isn't that
you're using money to do that it means
that is what makes it money I don't
think you could make the same argument
with a crypto what do you want to what
are you going to say to we've created
the crypto coin because we used to use
this in medicine
well let me let me I wanted it I want to
say this I think because of you Dr Paul
you you made a lot of people
Millionaires and billionaires because
when your message was going around about
the US dollar being unsound based on
these policies there were a lot of
people that were trying to figure out
what they could do to store their value
properly of course gold and silver were
big but when Bitcoin emerged a whole
bunch of Libertarians and people who had
heard your message said I'm gonna check
this thing out
and they bought a bunch and 10 years
later there were 300 400 million dollars
because governments all over the world
are buying crypto and trying to use it
many people have have decided for
whatever reason it has value to them and
the early adopters who were paying
attention to the problems of the US
dollar they got to rise along with it
so what does that prove I don't know if
proves anything I just think like if
they listen to you for whatever reason
they ended up becoming very well yeah
but the one thing for sure I wasn't
giving uh investment advice right no I
mean it turns out it's okay but I might
have been talking about agriculture yeah
you could go out and buy land Jimmy
Rogers oh yeah that's what we should do
about and and that serves that function
but I think that that's a little bit
different uh I I the way I answer those
questions is uh you know does that mean
you want to be cautious and make some
rules about about Bitcoin no I'd let the
market decide whether people really want
Bitcoin or not uh and and uh they they
uh I was I go to a lot of uh Bitcoin
crypto meetings and things especially
early on and at these meetings I became
a little bit nervous because they had
one individual there that they were
hovering around and these are the people
that was running the conference they
were hovering around this woman that
said oh she had had experience with
Washington DC as a lobbyist in ways and
means and will protect you when they
start writing the laws about and I
thought
no you don't need you
that's that's not my my way of looking
at it I mean if if it's designed mainly
to prevent fraud or something like that
you have to be able to but I I just
think that you don't need laws uh you
know to tell people uh how to protect
against gold what concerns me about
tying money to a hard thing like gold is
that someone can steal all the gold
like if we tie it to anything then that
thing can be taken and hoarded by
someone
maybe maybe but they've uh you know the
the uh uh they see the the silver people
back in the 70s uh Hunt Brothers they
cornered the market and they took it up
when silver was five dollars or three
dollars they took it up to fifty dollars
they were hoarding it wow but the market
came along and took care of it but real
quick Ian bitcoin's been stolen tons of
times it just it happens all the time
yeah they find ways and right now gold
is at an all-time high Bitcoin just hit
above 30 000 today as well uh and I
remember doing my coverage of currency
collapses in Venezuela and in Zimbabwe
and we were talking about this a little
bit before the show before our currency
kind of collapses a lot of different
things happened before it does there's
many things that happen in many
different years and then all of a sudden
when it drops it drops quickly and the
effects are one by one by one by one and
and and it goes by so fast people are
shocked and surprised do you think that
is possible in the United States do you
see a possible currency collapse and
potentially on what kind of time scale
now I don't think it's possible it's
going to be it's going to happen
inevitable so it will it because they
can't keep uh keep doing this but uh you
know you mentioned that uh you know some
of those people that took my advice I
wonder if they're going to give me a cut
on what they make you know no it just
happened that uh it was an alternative
and so far the alternative has made a
lot of people rich but do you think
there were 10 people 100 people 5 000
people or or a million people that
bought that bought cryptocurrency or
crypto between 30 and 68.
and it's on the way up and then on the
way down there's a lot of buying it's
hell and so so it is some people make a
log but but the whole thing is is I want
a definition I mean you could they can
do it it would be legal as long as
there's no fraud involved but it you
still have to have a definition I can
define
a uh a gold dollar and for us it was uh
it was not rounded off but you know at
the time of the Constitution they had a
precise weight of silver which was the
real monetary issue but it uh it was the
the gold was at uh you know 42 dollars
an ounce you know and uh you know 26 22
26 dollars an hour and that would stay
there for a long long time and but that
didn't prove anything other than we had
a lot of gold and we would it's sort of
like the uh the Romans did they they had
Advanced their that they'd Advanced
their uh Kingdom and and uh and go out
and steal all the gold from the people
and uh in a way we have advanced you
know our Empire and we have become very
wealthy but now we're consuming it we're
consuming it so definitions will change
according to that but you still know uh
you know it was twenty dollars an ounce
and then it went to thirty five dollars
an ounce cheated the American people
total fraud and then it was released in
71 and it went to 800 an ounce then it
had to be the market adjusting and
that's a benefit the market will sort
that out but uh but the definition is
gone my argument is you have to have a
definition if you want to have a sound
economy and the world has never been on
a Fiat currency to the extent that we're
uh that we have now with the with the
paper money dollar I just want to make a
quick correction gold is not an all-time
high but near all-time high so I'm sorry
if I misspoke I wanted to it's closed
yes I wanted to ask you about uh
military intervention and War and all
that stuff I know that you are one of
the biggest opponents of the US getting
involved overseas and I'm curious your
thoughts on where we've gone since you
were in Congress has it gotten worse and
what your views are
well the principle has gotten much worse
they even they've endorsed the the
principle and uh the big thing was uh
probably one that is is annoying to me
was uh because I remember it and that
was we had World War One World War II
and we went through the you know the
process of declaring war and having an
enemy and it did uh I think they could
have been avoided but but it was done
the right way in a sense that we
declared the war and the wars didn't
last that long we were only an hour a
year or so on a World War one and World
War II is three years let's think of how
that was taken care of but after the war
and I remember this uh this uh issue
very clearly because it was in 51 50 51
you know when uh when Truman said oh he
never probably made an announcement we
have to have a police action we have to
go in you know preserve democracy for
Korea and my comparison was yeah and
look we wanted to do that in South Korea
and uh we we lose 60 000 people and kill
millions of the Vietnamese and all this
and then we lose and we walk away lost
all this money in all these lives and
what happened was there a uh this these
are just realistic arguments but uh it
was was there the domino effect that's
what we were preached to your domino
effect it's going to Communism is going
to take over and they did a lot of that
but guess what when we lost the war in
Vietnam we we left and uh all of a
sudden something weird happened uh they
started acting like capitalists
and and just think of all we want in
peace versus all that we lost in war and
sometimes people won't even think of the
slightest consideration that maybe a
little bit of that philosophy could be
applied to those people who are looking
forward to a war with China
I feel like it's it's like a Chinese
finger trap that you've got so many
people who want war and they make the
argument we need to go there to stop
Russia we need to go there to to stop
the terrorists but in doing these things
in engaging in foreign intervention it's
creating recoil or creating blowback and
it's making the conflicts worse it's
making it's by Design I mean that's what
keeps the machine running you know
that's what keeps the money flowing we
talk about the FED all the time the FED
is what makes War possible is what makes
the Empire possible and it's funny
because you sit around and you laugh at
the Domino thing oh man that's that's
like you know that's like something out
of the 60s we're living in it right now
if we don't stop Russia in Ukraine
they're going to be marching through
Paris you know tomorrow they're gonna
they're gonna take Estonia where's
Estonia I have no idea but they're going
to take it
so we still believe in the Domino Theory
it's still the basis of our foreign
policy in fact who was it it was a
politician it actually may have been
McCarthy speaker of the house and I
could be wrong who said um well we got
to fight him basically he literally said
we got to find him over there because
otherwise we're going to find him over
here I mean I thought the bush era was
over right so these things are just
regurgitated because they're enormously
profitable to the most well-connected
people you know the only value I see to
in foreign intervention is that fascism
sometimes can be extremely peaceful
that's one of the worst things about
fascism is it's insidiously quiet I mean
modern fascism it's it's capitalists
they buy they they run your social media
they make you see things you don't
understand and so at some point if you
don't do anything it will just will
happen around you let me try to
elaborate on what you're I think what
you're saying is what we're seeing with
big Tech what we're seeing with the
establishment this authoritarian
takeover subverting our systems buying
people out and slowly creeping and
taking things over is that yeah
BlackRock these these Mega corporations
that are buying land and things like
that's that's it's happening in the name
of Peace because it's they're being done
with dollars but I don't I don't know if
fascism is the right word because some
people might take the word fascism
literally but we're seeing you know
state with State Street Vanguard
BlackRock corporatism corporatism
they're buying everything up there using
the system against us and exploiting it
and it's not just that these these big
uh uh hedge funds and and firms they're
getting Federal Reserve money basically
infinitely printed and given to them to
do this so it's the lucrative I guess
fascism is probably the right way to say
it the lucrative merger of Corporation
and state to to take over the whole
system under Mussolini's definition and
I think you are correct in some some
instances there especially with a lot of
these institutions like BlackRock having
lucrative contracts now in Ukraine
there's a lot of business deals there's
a lot of politicians Sons and Daughters
who have a lot of interests in that
particular region but I kind of wanted
to ask both of you guys if you guys were
the Secretary of State how do you handle
the Ukraine situation right now what's
the call call to action
well I have a real easy thing to do it's
not complex and everybody will
understand it but nobody will do it
because I used it in my debates you know
how are we going to end the wars in the
Middle East yeah we've sort of come
around to your position and we should
have done it but here we are we're there
and I and my answer is we just marched
in we can just March out yes and I
remember uh you had a statement where
you said if someone is given the wrong
prescription you don't just keep giving
them the same prescription you stop that
sounds pretty good did I say that you
did say that yes it's brilliant and I
heard that and I said I don't see it any
other way if we all agree it's wrong we
just stop
yeah and I think it's fair to say that
uh they've been prescribed crack crack
cocaine and heroin and Fentanyl all
mixed into one and they're high as a
kite and they're they're doing really
horrible things especially with with
what's happening in Ukraine right now
there's so many innocent ukrainians
dying there's so many innocent young men
dying in that specific region and and I
think you know the main reason we didn't
blow each other up during the Cold War
was as was because of negotiations was
was because we were able to actually sit
at the table and negotiate we're not
even doing that now which which is just
absurd and crazy in my opinion I asked
him last night what he would do and he
was like Well we'd be like we'd take our
troops out and negotiate some sort of
economic you know resolution with Russia
and I don't know Ron do you think that
that would be ethical to because I think
what they're trying to do is take
Sebastopol the the warm water trade port
in the Black Sea yeah but by what
happens when there's sincere efforts
either with China or Russia that we
could pursue uh I mean the Deep state
which is uh not Republican not Democrat
they're deep into control in the whole
system they make it so that you you
become a heathen you become a Nazi or
you they'll give you all kinds of names
you know uh and you're unpatriotic
that's the thing I was when I wanted to
bring the troops home I was unpatriotic
and I didn't care about the troops I
said how could you argue that I just
want to bring them home so they don't
get killed yeah more more troops donated
to you than any other presidential
candidate people forget about that and
you were one of the only anti-war voices
out there that was finally getting at
least a little bit of attention on the
corporate media even though it was
skewed even though when you're polling
high they made sure that they looked
like you were polling low they played so
many underhanded tricks against you I
was wondering um Can can you talk to
that a little bit and and how do we
navigate this media sphere when they
control the narrative and they're
playing so unfair
well I I still I resort to something
that I find my comfort zone and that is
that I'm not there I I don't have the
ability nor is the support there to
really change it you know uh I want to
audit the Fed so people understand it I
don't say okay the litmus test if you
care about anything at all you have to
sign on to my bill that the Federal
Reserve is abolished in two weeks you
know and and so I I wanted people just
have to you know discuss it and that's
what happens it gets turned down we have
opportunity we could talk to China a lot
more you know I thought it was pretty
exciting when uh when the Great Nixon
decided to sneak over to China and it
was an exciting time people think boy
you know maybe they will change and they
did but the big problem is that we won't
admit is they'd be paying pretty darn
good capitalism you know they've sold us
stuff and they took our money and
invested it and uh and what do we do we
steal the money from the people and then
we've invested to the
military-industrial complex could go
over and drop bombs on people then we
say I wonder why they don't like us I've
been thinking lately if we could
repurpose our military industrial
complex to start building drones in like
by the tens of millions and then take
them out into space and blow them up for
training and then put on board
Artificial Intelligence on the drones
the drones can tell us what we're doing
wrong make us better at fighting drone
swarms and then we can not blow people
up because I think I still want to make
it profitable for Lockheed Martin but I
don't want to hurt the people with
Lockheed Martin okay let me try I I
think you come you bring up an actual
interesting point and I'll put it I'll
rephrase it I think I think I understand
the military-industrial complex is going
to move towards the path of least
resistance and that is they need War to
stay in power and and they want war so
they Lobby for war they get more money
from the government so what we need is
to divert their profits into nonsense
like building drones in outer space so
they keep getting lucrative contracts
but eventually fizzle out of existence
because they're they're being given
money for the government to do literally
nothing yeah they don't need War they
need profit and they think that war is
the most profitable thing right now but
if we could create a more profitable
system I.E drone defense there's one
statistic you have to deal with and uh
I'm not I'm not going to argue this is
authentic but I read it so so it's ugly
but they say people who get involved in
this kind of stuff in the military and
all five percent of them are so or
Psychopaths they love war it isn't just
the money they they love power they love
money and a few of them are sort of bad
news Psychopaths like that they enjoy
hurting other I know that they like
seeing how their weapons train on real
people like they want to see what how it
works well this is where this was the
article that they were arguing that case
had some people well you see it in
domestic life all the time you know some
of you know it just was so astounding to
me when uh it's too too common now to
even be news but somebody would be
robbing a store if somebody would be
lying on the floor just trying to hide
and the hoodlum comes in it just fills
the person with bullets I mean that
that's just can I I want to ask you um
uh
going back to the you know you're
talking about the 50s or 60s and 70s
World War II
I'm not uh I'm I'm 37 I'm curious with
everything we're seeing in today with
political conflict as you mentioned with
crime was it at all like this in the 60s
70s and the 50s or anything like that
well I I wrote something recently that
uh what it was like in 1945 because
everybody said the world's going to end
tomorrow and things are very very bad
and I agreed with that I talk about it
all the time but then I just went over
the statistics of World War uh World War
one and World War II millions of people
died you know and it was it was very a
disaster so it's it's continued but the
founders made the point and I'm a strong
believer in it that ultimately the kind
of society we have depends on a
prevailing attitude both intellectually
and spiritually of of a community
because uh you know the non-aggression
in principle fortunately is can be used
by people in a spiritual realm or in a
pragmatic Zone you know just say this
this doesn't this doesn't make any sense
and uh yet uh yeah we we continue to do
it but I think it's the nature of
mankind and I I never I never heard
discussions uh about nihilism of course
that's been discussed in the philosophy
books for a long time but nothing like
it's talked about now and I've sort of
been concentrating on that at that
because if you don't have truth which we
don't have anymore uh then you have
dialists and you're dealing with people
that have no conscience
and when you understand that then you
understand the people who just shoot to
kill and and do all these things and do
all and what that's going to cause chaos
and people are going to die ah that will
open the doors for True Marxism we have
to get rid of all this garbage you
people of living with so for us to
devise you you know the the perfect
social State we need to get rid of all
these Notions of about about freedom and
capitalism and honest money and that is
their their goal and and since they're
nihilist they don't care so do you think
that the reason we're seeing the spike
in crime is that
these people are intentionally releasing
criminals and and you know making not
enforcing laws because they want to
destroy the system well I think that
they've just lost all contact with
reality I think they are Psychopathic in
essence a psychopath has lost the uh you
know contact with reality and uh and and
that sort of can be a collective thing
the mob psychology I mean we're we're
operating sort of with a mob psychology
that people are joining us uh and they
have all kinds of excuses I I've been
you know as much as I try to think about
this uh you know getting all these
corporations and so many people to go
along with this lockdown you know and
most of them are you know you think they
they they can't be they can't be as far
off as I described but they uh they just
go they go along with it and uh it's
it's sort of scary but I think I think
the person so the uh the the point that
the founders made is uh they said this
constitution isn't worth much if the
people are immoral and have no
principles and they don't believe in
truth how can they believe in honest
money if they don't have any principles
and and they don't have a a unit of
account they don't have a unit of
account for the money they don't have a
unit of account for social matters
perhaps this is why they're saying two
plus two equals five
which was a a big thing they're still
pushing to be honest what is a woman you
said something that's it that's a good
example you said something really
profound about the non-aggression
principle in in regards to spirituality
like I know about non-aggression
principle militarily but the idea that
in a community in a conversation you
could have a non-aggression principle
with another human and that if you live
like that maybe it'll create a society
where then that starts to happen but it
happens all the time I've made
optimistic statements and I have to be
careful because it sounds too optimistic
I say I remember growing up as a kid in
a depression in World War II I was in uh
grade school and high school College
medical school military and I said
there's hardly anybody that I met that I
thought was a real scoundrel
my neighbors had been easy to get along
with and and and and and and and we
happen to be Believers so the people we
associated with in a spiritual way they
were never a threat to us so there were
a lot so my impression if it was my
narrow impression but people most people
would say yeah buddy what a boring life
you had you know and and they wouldn't
accept this because life is much
different and you have to you have to
have a good time too you know well the
the old curse may you live in
interesting times yeah so maybe it's
kind of good when your life is boring
you get to focus on your passions you
get to take care of your family it's
good to be forceful in your life but not
necessarily aggro like there's
difference a different in B in like
forcing your personality and beliefs on
someone and being aggressive with it
well this is this is the issue I see
today we have what we would refer to as
the left and the right or whatever words
you want to use to describe you know
wokeness and freedom or whatever one
faction says lie cheat and steal because
the only truth is power or there is no
truth but Power the other side is an
amalgam of different ideologies that all
tend to agree on the rights of the
individual so I think while all of us in
this room May disagree on certain you
know principles or philosophies we
mostly agree with life liberty and the
pursuit of happiness and that's where we
differ with those who seek to use
aggression against us or others to
control them and gain power we actually
think people should be free to live
their lives you know but I I think
people uh the shortcomings comes from
I'll use the word conservative but the
conservative element sometimes wants to
tell you exactly how you should live but
if a conservative who wants to do that
accepts the principle of non-aggression
yes he can be critical he might want to
approve it because if it happens to be
somebody your family or a friend and
they're they're killing themselves with
drugs and all that you might you know
try to help people but I I I think that
the people uh you know you know will
respond but uh the the problem is is
that that there's this momentum and I
think economics have a lot to do with it
you know because things things uh even
though there's still a lot of wealth in
this country and and people are think
they're a lot richer than they really
are because it's all on debt and uh
that's why bad times are coming because
it's going to get worse when they know
how poor they really are well there's a
couple questions I have for you why do
you think we're seeing this explosion of
homelessness in so many major cities and
why is it that they are at the same time
I think is it related don't get me wrong
but I'm bringing them both up they say
that it's hard to find workers but we're
also seeing them this this wave of
unemployment I'm sorry of homelessness
you'd think those two things would solve
themselves I I think it's a reflection
of a stupid policy welfarism and uh that
means uh they know it look what look
what happened when the when the covet
broke out and people wanted to take
advantage of it everybody got checks big
checks and they have so much money that
they printed it sitting around how are
we going to spend all so they feel they
feel like they can trust that but the
trouble is is the payment comes in a
different way the taxes are very high
much higher than they really think the
liquidation of debt the default people
keep worrying about will the government
not send me my check is there going to
be a default the default is Rip roaring
and it's going to get a lot worse that
means that if I owed you a hundred
dollars last week week and I can give it
to you today it's only worth fifty
dollars you've lost fifty dollars and
governments do that they steal from you
and they transfer wealth and that's
that's where the real problem and people
don't understand that because they say
the one statement I've heard for so many
years is the people who get into trouble
as a result of the stupid government
they say uh the the only problem I have
is I don't have enough money to pay pay
my bills I go to the grocery store and
it's 200 and I only have a hundred
dollars so it's always a shortage of
money and the problem is there's too
much money printed out of thin air and
it doesn't have value to it there's no
unit of account so having a unit of
account and social things and economic
matters I think are very similar this is
how I explained to people I went on to
Amazon and I was searching for a tablet
put it in my shopping cart and I think
it was like four hundred and seventy
dollars I forgot to buy it
two days later or so I go back on Amazon
and there's a notice it says a price
change for an item in your cart I click
it and it says this item is now six
hundred dollars
this is the easiest way for the average
person to understand how inflation is
happening so rapidly
it was I I could have bought it two days
ago for you know 150 bucks less well
that means if you were if you if you did
a pla if you made a plan and said okay I
make X dollars per hour I have why bills
and the tablet cost Z that means I have
to work this many hours to be able to
buy this tablet at the end of the month
so you work those hours and then by the
time the end of the month comes the
tablet now costs twice as much because
you weren't actually making any money as
you were working your job and saving you
are losing money
see uh free market Austrian econ economy
is completely different than keysianism
casinism believes in the computer you
put in the numbers and they'll tell us
print a hundred dollars here and the
people will do this it's not true it
never works out because one one the
principles of Austrian economics that
has helped me understand it is the uh is
the uh
artificiality of it it's the the uh
pseudo theory that that you can't you
can't measure things that way because
there's a psychological Factor there and
uh it's it's how bad we want so if if we
doubled the money supply in this room uh
we're not all going to do the same thing
you can't you can't tell what the people
will do what they're measuring be some
might save it some might spend it that's
why that's why this Theory this
subjective theory of value I think
explains it that's why it's a mishmash
that's why you can go you know uh 10 10
years and gold prices doesn't move and
yet they've been predominated like crazy
then all of a sudden we have our our
prices going up but that's all
explainable through Austrian economics I
I did find that really interesting that
the price of gold has been fairly
stagnant I think over the past 10 years
is that artificial is it being
artificial well there's a lot of money
that's the most important price fixing
that they can do because the goal we
eventually will measure value no matter
they will be the unit of account and uh
that's the last thing that they have to
cling to uh to say that uh the dollar
still has value and they've been able to
manipulate boy ever since Roosevelt went
in and took the gold in it was 35 an
hour and all that but they they I think
even today they can manipulate that
price of gold and oh I'm way off I was
way wrong on that sorry but they will
have to uh you know eventually there's
gonna there's gonna be chaos from them
and that's why we would like to try to
avoid it real quick just a correction in
January of 2001 gold was 265 an ounce it
reached a peak around September of 2011
at 1700 it dipped Down August 2015 to
1121 and as of today it is bouncing
around near 2000 and officially crossed
to 2018 so actually
it skyrocketed after the first economic
crisis went down a little bit and then
skyrocketed back up again with the past
economic crisis so yeah gold is gold is
way up okay that thousand dollars was
his 19th uh 2015 or something yes
I watched that as the beginning of the
current bull market in Gold because you
had bull market 35 up to 800 then you
had a thousand up to uh well what the
second one but this is the third one
where it was a thousand dollars now it's
up to two thousand dollars and I think
it's just the beginning if you look at
percentages of what happens in a bull
market in Gold what's the percentage
going from 35 up to 800 even though it
didn't stay there that's that's the
movement that it had 250 percent or
something like that is it it's possible
it's more more than that it's possible
we'll see like a 10x increase in the
cost of gold the value of gold I don't
know what you call it cost or value is
the same is the the word interchangeable
well I like to could you see gold going
up by one magnitude from 2000 twenty
thousand an ounce yeah I think it'll go
to zero I mean I think it won't be in
trading I mean I think the dollar will
go to zero before that but no yes it
will if they've held it together longer
yeah yeah I think in your lifetime
you'll see gold at five thousand dollars
an ounce if they can keep it from
totally crashing the economic system I I
I agree I'm looking at this chart right
now and it compares the dollar the Dow
Jones the S P 500 and gold and if in the
year 2000 you invested all your money in
Gold it would be worth twice as much as
stock in the Dow Jones or s p 500. did
you compare it to crypto uh if you
bought Bitcoin uh around uh 2009 or
whatever it would be worth twenty
thousand percent so from the beginning
from the beginning and do it
from when 2015 was 2016 was when gold
was a thousand bucks so I think 2016
would be a interesting metric from 2016.
yes so let's uh let's do this do this so
if you were to buy Bitcoin in
okay why is it okay there we go
2016. yeah let's say it lets me go back
to 2018. bitcoin was at eight thousand
dollars today it's at thirty thousand
dollars so it's
so you could look at charts and probably
prove almost anything you want on the
short run you must you mentioned and uh
I'll just put it this way in the past
five years Bitcoin is up 113 gold is 53
S P 500 is 52. Dow Jones is 35. if you
go back to uh the year 2000 you know I
think is not necessarily relevant for
you know people my age then you would
have gained way more buying gold than
anything else
and then uh in the past five years the S
P 500 and gold are comparable you know
we all look at that we think about
Investments how do we protect our wealth
and that is important because that's how
do I live but uh ultimately if you look
at all those different Investments that
we have that we can do uh
I actually the only thing that's going
to be important to us is if we have our
freedom because because what did
Roosevelt do within one announcement a
month after he was in office he took all
the gold in by force it confiscated the
gold there was gold confiscation in the
United States many people don't even
know about it nobody owned nobody was in
the United States was a lot of on gold
from 1933 up till
1975 and that was that was when I was
trying to get gold legalized you know
that's a long time so that's uh that's
pretty amazing but I think one of the
most important metrics to look at is the
purchasing power of the dollar and when
you look at that and what it used to buy
you and now would it buys you I mean
there's horrible tragic stories of
individuals burying their money or
putting it underneath their couch and
I'm like you people don't understand one
of the biggest taxes out there is
inflation it's a hidden tax many people
don't know about it but the value of
your dollar of what you worked hard for
or is slowly being eviscerated by the
government and their irresponsible
Financial policies there was a story
where a young couple
uh open up the floorboards in their
attic and found a box that their
grandfather or that this guy's
grandfather had had hidden away with
fifty thousand dollars in it and boy
paper money and boy were they so excited
to find fifty thousand dollars and
they're like wow little do they realize
that it's basically a million dollars if
he had properly invested it because the
US dollar is not sound exactly and and
just seeing this happening because now I
think it's it's kind of quickening now
when you go to the grocery store you see
it more and more kind of evident and
more and more in your face not just what
egg prices but that has to deal with a
lot of other circumstances and
situations but overall when you're at
the grocery store when you pay for
everything it's a lot more than it was
before and that's not an accident we
just went to the grocery store and as we
are checking out the it was 200 bucks
for like one half bag of it was like
cheese tea some meat and some some
hummus and then we were like how is this
two hundred dollars what is it well it
was like 8 dollars for a little thing of
hummus it was it was eight dollars for a
pack of cheese and we were like yeah we
filled up a bag with you know some deli
meats some cheese some dips and some
drinks and they're like eight to ten
bucks each and it doesn't take a genius
to see all of this because during covid
they were like we're gonna give you guys
a two thousand dollar check but we're
gonna give you billion dollars more to
all the private entities and
corporations that were in business with
and and having that much of money just
printed out of thin air those two
thousand dollars were nothing compared
to the secret corporate and banking
bailouts that were given out to some of
the biggest institutions in the world
their losses were were were private
we're we're public we're publicized that
their profits were privatized this is a
this is a system that we're we're
dealing with right now that isn't
capitalistic this is socialism for the
super rich everyone else screw yourself
and this is a big notion that I think a
lot of leftists need to understand here
this is not capitalism this is this is
direct elitism socialism for the super
rich that are able to get away and do
whatever ever they want while everyone
else is being screwed over you know the
words that they use makes a big
difference too because even here and
I'll do it quite frequently but I try
not to ever refer to inflation as a CPI
and prices going up and me says I used
to say well that's just semantics just
just you know qualify it or something
but Misa said no that's on purpose
because if the price of such and such
went up that means profits they made too
many profits oh Labor's going up too
fast labor unions did that at the same
time if if we concentrate on the
inflation is back to the money if you
dilute the money supply by printing
money that that is the culprit that's
the inflation so I try never to talk
about the CPI well it showed a lot of
inflation last year but this is this is
a trick many leftists use I see them say
something like the economy is not doing
poorly these corporations brought in
record profits and it's like yes
inflation is at 15 percent so if a
corporation brings in say 10 billion
more dollars and they they typically
bring in 100 million dollars it is just
Rising with inflation that is to say the
buying power of what they brought in is
the same but the monetary number is
bigger therefore it's the corporation's
fault for making record profits and
that's the trick they use to say see
capitalism's the problem these
corporations are making record profits
while you're suffering no the reason you
can't buy milk bread and eggs is because
it's six bucks for a carton of eggs
right now and so that means those
corporations their costs have gone up
the same and so their profit percentage
is the same but the number is bigger
because of inflation yeah yeah talking
percentages and not in in finite amounts
when you want to talk about profits
that's a good point those are the tricks
they use to be like oh how did they make
50 billion this year you know Ron you
mentioned um units of account and how
our money is lost a form of account and
that gold was our used to be the way you
would account for money and then you
said something about social account a
unit of account for social social units
of account what did you mean by that
well I think you have to have a value
the nihilists have a value truth doesn't
exist the other one is there is truth
out there and uh and it it might not be
you might not have the same definition
but it principle all the way back to
before Hammurabi wrote his code they had
an idea and the code uh would would
Define
even back then when it was such a
primitive era they said you should kill
people you shouldn't steal from people
and it's a higher law it's a higher law
that was known to all civilizations and
uh I think that you have to have have
that but it's a Truth Versus nihilism is
a good way to do it but I think it's
also a higher law which has been known
about and accepted on uh you know from
the beginning of time from time of Adam
and Eve it implies right and wrong good
and bad and if you have that you have no
unit account on social order so is this
like um social credit score kind of like
this is it like a an aberration of of
what we're supposed to think is truth
like truth is what they tell you it is
as opposed to truth is don't kill people
I guess I guess it could be but the
social credit thing I don't want to get
near that one I agree and I wonder if
losing touch with our unit of account
from the Bible I was never really raised
in that way religiously but I think that
there's value to it like that if we lose
touch with that then another form of
account will come in the way you account
to the state something like that I think
the woke left have no moral framework
it's just power and then the traditional
judeo-christian values of the United
States is a moral framework so I think
that's a big dividing point in the
culture War those who and I said this
before uh Bill Maher is a great example
of this he says he's an atheist he
doesn't believe in God but he holds all
of these Christian values such as the
right uh presumption of innocence which
is rooted in the story of Sodom Gabor as
the principal example I tend to use but
here's a guy who was raised in a society
that held these values to be true he
then says but I don't believe about I
don't believe anything about a man in
the sky or a resurrection or anything
and that's those stories are totally
separate from the moral values of
presumption of innocence for example
and so he grows up he lives a life and
he says I don't believe those stories
but I'm going to tell you we have to
hold these values true
when people then grew up completely
outside of that religion that never even
hearing the stories or any of those
values they don't recognize presumption
of innocence what do they recognize the
only thing that matters is how powerful
you are and what you can take
very well I've got a burning question I
wanted to ask you at the beginning of
the show Ron and I'll ask you now if you
had the internet in 1976 before you ran
for Congress would you have started a
YouTube channel instead
I had trouble starting in 1982 or 1992.
no I'm not it uh I think about it in
theory and in principle and usage and
the practicality on how you get the
information out and my job I spend most
of my time is trying to understand
things that's why I was fascinated with
just the fundamentals of Economic Policy
if it was the Leonard Reed in the
foundation for economic education to me
this was exciting and I used to Kid
myself I said boy I'm sure glad I found
these people that agree with me and of
course it was the other way around
because it's it's been there a long time
so I I think that uh you know people
people you know can't find the thing but
that to me was the most interesting
thing is to search I think once you
discover that you're not going to know
you know we might just say we all agree
on the general principles that sounds
good having truth and non-aggression
principle but each one of us would might
apply it a little bit differently
because the one thing the conservatives
can't do is leap over this and accept
you know somebody else's personal
behavior and then they want to regulate
that that means they've leaped over uh
too far and that means they have to use
Force to do that that's why the idea of
aggression has to be very very definite
you said something at the very beginning
of the show about uh there being no
honest people in Washington DC or
something that effect and I wanted to
say this right away but I can think of
at least one I can think of more than
one but to be fair at least one and
that's Rand Paul who uh your son
obviously and then you also mentioned
you know had kids in college and I think
that Rand is one of the only politicians
that I think is doing a good job that
actually is doing right I think they're
all far from perfect but everyone's
human and then there's people like
Thomas Matthew I think is doing a
tremendous amount she's very good I'm
wondering what your thoughts are on uh
on the current state of Congress and
obviously I assume you think your son's
doing a good job but I'm curious to hear
your thoughts well once again I don't
get into the detail of that be I've I've
over the years don't even like using
their names one time we had a little
rally after they did allow me and uh in
in in the uh at the time of the election
they they didn't permit me to speak at
the convention and uh I um so we had our
own rally I think I was where were we in
Florida I was there it was a great event
well anyway it was and uh I think I
spoke on average about an hour or so and
I did and the crowd was it's just great
and I never said I never say oh I gave a
great speech I say the crowd makes your
speech it has me made all the difference
and so I uh I was uh you know just
really amazed you know at the reception
that we got there so it was huge it was
a stadium there was multiple stadiums uh
in Florida that that particular year as
well and there was multiple shows and
multiple people being like this is a
representation of the people that's not
being represented by the corporate media
that's not being represented by the
political class and there was so much
discontent because finally we had a
voice that was being heard but it was
being censored by the media I was being
downranked everywhere which was crazy
well when I finished that speech
somebody came up to me it might have
been a friendly reporter or somebody
that wasn't coming matter of fact it
maybe was a criticism I didn't know it
he he personally came up he says you
know you talk for over an hour he says
and who who were my opponents and see
that was uh was was Trump was no I don't
think that was Trump I think that was
Romney Romney had it yeah Gingrich no
who was the Democrat
um that was uh 2008 Obama and Hillary
and the guy came up and he says you
talked for an hour he says you never
mentioned either
either bonus so I mean I didn't mention
the Republic order the Democrats so I I
put that down on the list well I think
it's a distraction and I I never enjoyed
it even though I have to admit that I've
been getting pretty sloppy and Daniel
has to put up with it because what I do
is there's one person that does upset me
and it happens to be a woman and that
doesn't mean I don't like women I mean
that's Nancy Pelosi
I think she's a nihilist oh yeah a
narcissist power hungry if I could just
ask you throughout all of your years
surrounding by all all of these horrible
people in Congress do you attribute what
they're doing because of malice or
ignorance why do you think they were
doing what they were doing why do you
think they're such a cause for bad let
me just simplify that Luke are they
stupid or are they evil yes sure that's
yeah that's better yes yes
I I think that the the problem that I
look at is intellectual and philosophic
I we we started a conversation with
talking about uh you know 1913 and I
said even a little earlier uh I think
people are influenced by that type of
thing and the control of the scenario
the control the propaganda uh is the
real is the real problem now the
individuals they're sloppy they're not
well informed uh you know I had people
come up some liberal Democrats when I
first went there in the 70s they'd come
up and they say I can't figure out what
you're doing why are you voting with
this guy over here and I just sort of
laugh because I kind of charge out of it
but uh no there's and I I think there's
there that's where we're making progress
I think people are that's why I love to
see young people talking about these
issues I think most of people don't know
how much influence they have because I
certainly don't believe some of the
things people tell me about all you do
this but if people all you have to do is
to have a small small group if you have
10 people
you know and you're not you're even
denied the information you'll never know
well how many people watch your show we
probably got about 50 000 or more right
now but but you don't know what that
might do in the next 10 years well one
thing by the way things change ideas and
I'll say this to you and one thing I've
only started realized you know maybe
like a year ago is people tell us when
they're watching they're actually
watching with three or four other people
so it says one but it's actually a
family or it's a group of friends who
are hanging out but I'll say this to you
uh Dr Paul and Congressman uh I don't I
don't I don't know if I would be here
right now if you were not doing what you
were doing you know throughout your
entire career the things that I started
learning online the speeches that I saw
from you had had a tremendous influence
and I think Luke obviously the same
thing he's at your rallies so you may
get started with this one idea and as
you mentioned you tell the 10 people
those 10 people tell 10 more those 10
people tell 10 more and before you know
it 30 years goes by and you're sitting
on some dude's podcast who's like
remember that one thing you said about
the wrong prescription for war and
you're like oh did I did I say that like
yeah I had a huge impact on my view of a
lot of the stuff too so I think you know
there's probably a lot of people people
out there right now who hear even this
show and we don't even realize okay I
always and more private conversations
when we get into these talks like this I
always want to know more about you know
where you were why you changed what
happens and I don't do it for you to say
nice things about me but what what was
it that caught your attention uh mine is
a little more a bit more more complex I
narrowed down the monetary issue but do
you remember
what it was that well it got your
attention I voted for Obama in 2008 I
had seen a lot of things on the internet
I had a lot of friends I had I had heard
about you I had seen the revolution
stickers and things like that I think
that was around that time it's it's you
know it's been a long time but I
remember uh I remember Barack Obama was
supposedly going to be the anti-war guy
that the bush the bush era was
completely wrong people are Marching
through the street saying he was Hitler
and then I'm this young kid and I'm
listening to punk rock music war is bad
war is wrong blah blah blah and I agree
I'm like I don't understand why why we
keep hearing these stories about
civilians being killed I don't
understand and I research it and I learn
about it and I start to understand the
history and I read about you know Desert
Storm and things like that I was a lot
younger I read about the Cold War and
then I say I don't trust the government
Barack Obama is supposedly going to be
hope and change and I'm young and naive
and people tell me you better understand
he's an Insurgent candidate he's not
supposed to be there it's supposed to be
Hillary she's she's the she's the
establishment vote for Obama and I'm
like wow is this really really the
change and you know one of the first
things Obama does when he gets into
office is he bombs a village of women
and children with a drone strike or I
think it might have been an airstrike or
something like that under the guise of
terrorist hunting and I was like okay
well that's weird but but maybe maybe
that was from the old Administration
like I'm gonna give him a chance and
then he surged our troops in Afghanistan
and then I just got really jaded and
angry and was just like so they lied to
me so that's the whole time sounds to me
like the war issue was a big issue for
you yeah absolutely and of course then
everything you had been saying about the
war was I started asking myself why is
it that it's this Republican candidate
who was preaching against War who's
still preaching against War who is his
now I can see as the track record of
actually caring about these issues and
then I started to see that hypocrisy in
these other liberal and Democrat voters
who told me they opposed the war but the
moment Barack Obama got elected they
stopped caring and I was like you lied
to me that put a chip on my shoulder and
I got deeply offended and distrustful of
these people and not to mention I never
liked Republicans as it was so what I
ended up seeing was more of
I I've never considered myself like a
right-leaning libertarian or a
conservative I remember seeing you give
certain speeches where I was like well I
don't agree with that but the one thing
I always said and I think the mises
caucus actually quoted me and they made
a little graphic was I thought to myself
you know this guy Ron Paul is saying you
know here's what I believe but you know
what I think the government should leave
you all alone and I thought to myself
well okay I can vote for that he
couldn't believe whatever he wants as
long as he leaves me alone right and so
that that was a big factor and you know
I would consider myself kind of like a
Centrist libertarian type more you know
like more freedom less less government a
little bit of government I'm not an
anarchist or anything like that but I
think I I think the the Obama being a
liar thing and it was kind of like they
spat on me they they lied to me they
insulted me and I just don't trust them
and I see you consistent I see uh and I
was I was a huge Bernie Sanders
supporter in 2015 and 16 for a similar
reason he was more what I thought of as
the left-wing version of you anti-war
Pro worker all these things sure enough
that was was another lie he ends up just
catering straight to the establishment
the moment they tell him to makes a
million bucks selling a book and then
says you could be a millionaire if you
write a book too and I'm like was all of
that a lie too I don't look I got to
imagine I just don't like any of these
politicians but you know you seem to
have retired with Grace and dignity and
remained consistent on all your
positions then you your son is in there
uh doing great work as well and I'm like
the these these These are the only few
politicians I actually think have ever
ever meant it to be honest but did they
ever try to buy you off did they ever
try to silence you or stop you no they
always insulted me they never came to
see me you think that if you no the
lobbyists didn't come did they come to
our office one time and you kicked them
out
I didn't you listen to him first you
listen to him first if you become
president in OA 2008 do you think that
they would have been like here's who
you're gonna bomb next and if you were
like no that they would have jfk'd you
uh well that's hard to say but uh
if if you did more than that if you
really changed things uh there'd be a
revolution uh that for some reason
whether they kill you or what but
anybody that supported it it would be
done it's not going to happen that's why
that's why he we have to expect the
collapse to come in a different way
nobody's gonna we can't get enough
people Congress to pass past the right
law to really change things it's good
that we have there and we have a few
more now than we did before you know
with the recent election but it's uh it
would be catastrophic if he really
changed it if you you can't close down
the fed the FED has to close themselves
down yeah you mentioned auditing the FED
at the time it was a 2009 or 10 or 11 or
something you're talking about auditing
the fed and I kept thinking no repeal
the Federal Reserve Act of 1913 repeal
but now what you're saying is that would
undercut pull the rug yeah well I want
to repeal that I've had bills into
repeal and it's just that uh I had I had
a lot of Democrats sign on to auditing
the fed and all the Republicans but they
wouldn't have I wouldn't have gotten
five votes to to abolish the Fed
there's a famous thing it was it was a
practice it became paragmatic but it was
also to me educational because I was I
was surprised we did that why why why
won't they vote for auditing
the FED I I what's what's their are
lobbyists coming at them are their lives
threatened uh well because there's that
money is being distributed secretly it's
it's a really a big privilege I think
that uh where was it I read I think it
was 31 trillion dollars they passed out
over covet but it's off the books I mean
they don't they don't go through
Congress you know to appropriate this
money it is and they don't want that to
be revealed that's why I said the thing
they want to protect the most are the
international transactions that's where
they wheel and deal and keep the bank
going International settlements that's
probably do a lot of the wheeling and
dealing and the bailouts are secret a
lot of the money is being moved around
no one even knows exactly where it's
going who is this going to I confronted
Ben Bernanke about this issue the guy
tried to steal my microphone from me
because I was like where's the money
going to how much money are you giving
people and this was all the way back in
2011. but but the good news is the
market is more powerful than the
politicians and that is why Brenton
Woods broke down that's why Henry
Haslett was right all through the 60s
were right and the people said it won't
work it won't work and finally it didn't
work and that's why the same people are
saying the dollar is going to get much
much weaker and they it will lose its
Reserve stand it's a it's a reserve
Reserve country uh credentials what do
you think is like a cogent move forward
to try and bring it into a slow Landing
soft Landing as soft as we can
you can't do that
but because the time has passed the best
example to know what we could have done
and should have done is 1921 because it
was a very serious depression it's 21.
and I I guess whoever was still in but
the keynesianism hadn't taken over they
just say you didn't bail people out you
know it's bad debt liquidate the debt
and get it over with so they did nothing
and after a little over a year the GDP I
think went down like 15 percent and then
everybody you know had to go back to
scratch and ever after that everything
was growth you know the markets were
growing again and you could have done
that and you could do it now but
politically it wouldn't be acceptable so
start businesses it's in the in the
private sector what if we were going to
do it like a soft Landing or something
it would be like by creating
productivity but not waiting for the
politicians well that's why the market
is important I think that you you could
you know if you took all of the dumb
economic things that Biden has done
especially in energy blowing up
pipelines you know doing all that
nonsense and more regulation if you
remove that that would be helpful that
would increase productivity and lower
prices but uh but the the debt is too
big that is going to haunt us and people
will worry rightfully so that that this
the debt will be liquidated uh and uh
they are going to default but the
default comes because the debt is
shrinking right now because of the money
is worth so little and they they can't
quit doing that you know they even talk
about you know raising interest rates
right now each day if they go if they
say one word to hint that well interest
rates are going to go up a little bit
you know the markets could add a
trillion dollars it's just crazy all
right it's beyond repair we're going to
go to super chats if you haven't done
ready would you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends and become a
member at timcast.com head over to
timcast.com click join us become a
member because we're gonna have an
uncensored members only show coming up
at about 10 10 p.m eastern time where
we're even going to take audience
questions and I I believe in this
segment we'll try and focus on cultural
issues that are currently happening
today which I really want to ask about
especially in a medical context I think
some of you may understand where I'm
going with that so we'll save that one
for the not so family-friendly after
show and uh in the meantime let's read
your super chats
so we have this one from Raymond g
Stanley Jr he says Ron sir thanks for
coming I literally just left my first
libertarian party regional meeting
thanks to D chord these folks are legit
four are running for local office others
doing work I was quite impressed sir
you're about to get up
are you in the bathroom was that a
question director no just just
here someone was just saying that they
uh one of our one of our audience
members saying that the libertarian
party is legit and they thank you for
coming
tell me what the schedule is like are we
we got about 30 minutes we're gonna do
super chats okay audience questions
yeah yeah how about now nope no problem
we'll read we'll read some super chats
and uh
do your thing all right
Chris o says Ron Paul is the most
principled inspirational political
figure of my lifetime thank you for
everything Dr Paul and thanks to Tim for
having him on uh I think thank you to Dr
Paul and Daniel for coming I mean this
is a it's an honor and a privilege one
thing I wanted to add too just just in
this context when uh Dr Paul asked me
about like What mattered to me is I want
to stress that I was very much in the
generic pro-choice Camp when I was
younger and then I heard Dr Paul talk
about life beginning of conception
explaining it and giving his reasoning
and that changed my view I wouldn't say
that I became pro-life or anything like
that but I immediately was like
interesting I understand now what he's
saying in terms of the pro-life context
life beginning at conception he's a
doctor he would know I respect that
argument and it changed my views and it
pulled me back closer I would say when I
was younger it was very much like who
cares abort the baby like what you know
punk rock and then I was kind of like we
should probably have some limitations on
this thing and so definitely he made me
because when I was younger I was
probably far left you know anarcho
leftist whatever that means and then I
got older I became more sensuous
libertarian type and I think Ron Paul
played a role in that for sure well it
tells a powerful story when he first
started he was in residency and he would
tell it better than I would but just as
an example that there was an abortion
that survived and the baby was lying in
the corner of the room and everyone just
was pretending that it wasn't there as a
baby gas for air because the point was
that that baby was supposed to be
aborted and he didn't have a real strong
view necessarily until that experience
and I think it really and it was I think
in the one book that he wrote about
abortion it really affected him so if
you're against violence that literally
is an act of violence you know
and personally I I just never liked the
government I don't know about you guys
but uh never thought about the
government everyone's calling you uh
Daniel mcbased in the comments by the
way
all right uh kite the twin blade says
it's happening
it is indeed it is indeed happening yeah
everyone's mentioning the meme yeah so
Liam McCallum says Dave Smith 2024 so
Ron Paul can be the last Federal Reserve
chairman ever would you would you accept
uh a chairmanship at the Federal Reserve
if you are nominated well you know
that's about the last thing that would
ever happen
well so I accept yeah as long as they
knew my rules my my first goal would be
to close shop
that's the point are you familiar with
Dave Smith Dave Smith yeah I'm gonna
grab the mic yeah oh yeah I grabbed the
mic too if you're when you're talking
about it okay yeah but Super Chat was
about to face a bit tired listening to
me oh no no never about Dave Smith
becoming president nominating you for
the Federal Reserve chair
yeah do you know Dave Smith yeah he may
be the maybe the 2024 libertarian
candidate I I'd hope so I know we'll see
but uh someone asked if he wins would
you accept an appointment to the chair
to chair the Federal Reserve
oh I I would but it wouldn't be living
in the Practical world you would be
shutting it down yeah I think we can
accept that all right Graham metal says
you woke me up in 2007 Dr Paul thank you
so much my entire Metals business that
is thriving is all because of you
hmm look at that
all right
what do we have here Frump says as an
older Millennial I voted for you wrote
you in and adored your view on what we
can be I appreciate Rand and his views
he's a solid guy please stay with us we
need another 23 plus years
well all right
Cloud Roth says Ron Paul makes me proud
to be an American
man it it is I I think I mentioned this
before but uh as you were talking about
you know you maybe say something to 10
people but then it you know at the time
goes on those ideas Ripple outward
may I I don't know if if you're aware of
just how many millions or even tens of
millions of people are where they are
politically economically because of what
of the work you did and how how profound
that was for so many people no but uh
that might be exagger's write it a
little bit but but we don't know that we
uh and I'm fascinated with the concept
of the remnant and uh I would say that
the people that are in this meeting here
tonight
pretty look like much like they're
dealing with retaining and maintaining
the beliefs in Liberty and you become a
Remnant and I've heard a little bit of
disagreement but I heard people in this
room that wanted to just hear the plain
truth of things and then that's to me
the wonderful thing and so you don't
know we don't know ah well you might
know you have the numbers how many
people listen but you don't know how
many people they talk to the next day so
that's what that's what's so miraculous
about it and I I think it's wonderful
somebody somebody asked me one time that
you know after having been up there how
did you ever put up with it you know
it's so disgusting and uh I said well
I'll tell you what it never bothered me
because you know obviously my goal was
not to be you know come a congressman or
the chairman of the Federal Reserve I
said so I just you know I did what I
thought I could do and in my own way but
you know I had low expectations and so I
tolerated quite well gormall says thank
you Dr Paul for everything you've done
and raising a remarkable son I would
love to hear your opinion on National
divorce
National divorce and that this is this
is a separate the good guys from the bad
guys huh well uh
I I don't know you know exactly what all
the details would be all I want is
freedom of choice and right now the
founders are rather astute in providing
for us a way to that we can move around
and if you didn't like one state you can
move around but uh no I'd like uh I'd
like the unit of government always to be
permitted and I think the most important
unit of government that we should have
is the individual self-government is
what we need and then the person is
totally responsible for everything he or
she does and you have to accept the
consequence but I think the other
principle in in this that you have to
look for is the principle of private
property rights owning property if you
know that it's your property and they're
not supposed to mess with it that uh and
if you're not allowed to mess with your
neighbor's property then we have to
accept the expansion of that which we
don't do very often in Washington is
that that if you can't do it if you
can't steal from your neighbor you're
not allowed to send the government there
you call the congressman I'll get that
from him he has too much stuff so we'll
get it so there's a couple principles
would uh so just that those principles
aren't complex and I think a lot of
people say yeah that makes sense I've
always the the compliment I like the
best is this why I like to listen to you
it makes common sense that's good you
know if it is it's not too complex and
uh and the direction we go in otherwise
if you want to uh get get the Keynesian
uh mathematical formulas I'll say well
if we do ABC you can get this and we can
you know all that nonsense and go no
that that doesn't work that'll put you
to sleep for sure hey what do we have
here a free thinking dog says how do we
get Libertarians and conservatives to
align today together we would be
unbeatable but we need to get
Libertarians back to some sanity
I would say the opposite of that we need
to get the other party back to some
sanity and stop trying to bomb people I
think the bush years had tremendous
damage to the Republican party and the
conservative party especially with all
the wars that they have started they had
the seat at the table they had the
Congress they had the Senate they had
the Supreme Court they had everything
and and they decided to go with
pointless Wars why would people trust
that they don't trust that and this is
what caused Obama to be as powerful as
it is this is what caused the kind of
woke moment to be where it is right now
a direct push back against the
conservatives sitting at the table and
then uh I would you know frankly say
pooping all over it I thought your work
was an example of Bridging the Gap
between libertarianism and the
Republican Party do you see do you see
well one I guess do you see a lot of
like cohesiveness between the two or or
would you like to
oh I would like to but I'm not sure it's
going to be uh all of a sudden the
reformation and the Republicans changing
their tune because right now the thing
that's fascinated me about bringing
people together is the fact that the uh
I'm disappointed that the traditional
Progressive Democrat uh that was an ally
when I was in Congress we've you know
the Dennis kucinich is we'd work
together and try to make the point of
the stupidity of the wars in the Middle
East and I got more support from
Democrats because Bush was in there so
it was political it was short-sighted so
that that is uh you know one thing that
we we could do is uh you know if if the
if the progressives are moving away
they're but they're acting more like uh
Hawks you know they they're joining the
Republican Hawks but at the same time
the Republicans are improving now they
have a little group up there that you
know got together with a remnant of the
the Progressive Democrats and they were
able to persuade people it's time we
have to think about no more money to
Ukraine you know so that's a start the
problem there is our practical problem
with Daniel I have to deal with yeah
that's all good but so often when we
find somebody oh yeah there's they want
to do this and we're doing too much
there what they want to do is for you to
build up the hatred toward China oh we'd
rather fight China that wears me out
yeah we did an episode of The Ron Paul
Liberty report I think it was uh last
week about this there was a political
story about how speaker McCarthy is
getting very nervous because he's got a
breakaway group of Republicans who are
willing to get together with
progressives who are breaking away from
their party and the the reason why it's
important is because there's a lot of
Leverage there McCarthy can only afford
to lose four votes on anything so if
you've got 10 people we saw all the
people that were holding up his uh
taking the chair if you've got 10 or 15
people or you know and they will line up
with three or four on the Progressive
side you literally have a third party in
Congress right now that has enormous
stopping power and you know it's it's
our sincere hope that they realize the
power they have one of the things that
they coalesced on is ending the
authorization for the Iraq War and
that's an easy one so start with the
easy things like that and realize how
much power a group of 10 people can have
in this kind of a close Congress I mean
that's one of the few areas I think for
optimism
Jim O'Brien says what are the pronouns
on the black shirt
told you so oh those are those are good
ones yeah that's that's on my shirt
saying that I uh identify as a
conspiracy theorist so oh okay infernal
Saxon says could a state government
audit the Fed
state government yeah well the state
governments are are doing good jobs
they've gotten together I have visited
some of their legislative bodies and
it's neat because they're taking they're
taking the Constitution literally and
they're saying only the only legal
tender the states a lot of use is Gold
and Silver so they're strictly they
don't have to ask the federal government
about this they're just and and it's
really pretty neat it's a good teaching
device we're not going to have magic and
change it but this is the kind of thing
that I think gets people's attention and
they start somebody might say I wonder
why the founders put that in there how
would we have a Federal Reserve well
maybe we don't need a Federal Reserve so
but there's about six states or so that
have worked on this and I'd like to see
the states really move in that direction
so we encourage that a whole lot to uh
to uh you know to argue the case for the
states to do something right on here in
gaming news says one thing is clear I'm
bringing marshmallows and toasting them
over the dumpster fire The Establishment
gave us Luke is a statist I missed you
Luke how dare you call me that if
there's one offensive thing you can call
me it is that I am highly offended
triggered a status seriously
two huh
all right let's see Winston Alexander
says Ian AI drones to pacify the
military-industrial complex WTF why not
direct the military industrial complex
into something productive like space
stations or spaceships I've got to do
that too so what I would want to do is
build drone swarms and then put onboard
Artificial Intelligence on the Drone
storms but don't give the Swarms weapons
just give them like sensor targeting
things so they can swarm us point target
our weaknesses and then give us what we
did wrong and tell us how to get better
at this why but because drone swarms is
the next stage of War but and and that
Ian's right there's videos talking about
drone the the Drone sword develop drone
swarm developments they've been working
on in Warfare where they can unleash
like 100
000 drones that can just they don't need
a nuke they just get these drones to all
crash into a city in perfect
synchronicity targeting the key point
it's crazy Precision but I would argue
maybe we just get government contracts
for assembly drones where the drones in
outer space build things yeah that'd be
cool yeah you can have like 100 trillion
drones in space all working in Synergy
to build size almost becomes irrelevant
when you're building in space you'll be
able to build planetary sized Dyson
spheres just build a Dyson Sphere space
exploration can we do a little bit of
that maybe yeah
bombing killing people yes Starships
launching soon Elon musk's Starship so I
get them on the show he's an offshore
isn't he uh I might DM him yeah hit him
up hit him up Tommy come on the job
let's talk about Twitter
all right let's grab some more
here in gaming news says Luke can
Anarchy save us or will the feds be
benevolent rulers
um I don't have a you know I I don't
know
you remember that yeah yes yes yes I I
can't predict the future but I know if
people follow the principles of the
non-aggression principle and
voluntarianism and become personally
responsible for themselves no matter
what happens they will be ready for
whatever comes and more prepared for it
and a lot in in a lot better situation
than if they weren't so I I think those
two ideas that you guys represent so
well and speak about for so many years
are critical at this juncture where
things are very crazy they're only going
to get a lot crazier from here and more
than ever we need to take care of
ourselves and our communities and I
think if we go along those lines uh
we're going to be ready for whatever
comes next wow um hequibus says Tim AGS
are 10 bucks for a dozen in Kami fornia
meanwhile at the castle we've got like
200 eggs it's in because we have we have
chickens we have like 30 of them so we
get you know we're getting like 27 eggs
per day some ridiculous number do you
have a farm Ron
not really I have a couple acres
I was raised in a in a way a chicken
farm than a dairy and I uh decided that
I wouldn't raise chickens at this
particular time have a couple cows but I
have a nice nice place and once again
it's back to my so-called optimism that
I just haven't run into a lot of ugly
people I mean this I know they're out
there and I suffer their consequences
but uh no uh we're our family feels very
fortunate that we've been I've been able
to practice medicine and we have a few
problems and it's been rather nice but
you I'm not a farmer you you would agree
though that chickens are pretty cool
I don't know I think they're sometimes
Pretty Dirty
yeah they're nasty little Poopers but
but I I think chickens are great can't
beat the eggs man fresh fresh eggs for
breakfast man and we had a garden so we
would pluck the cherry tomatoes I'd grab
some zucchini and then I'd make my own
breakfast right there you know Barry
rothball used to say well he says he
believes in the division of labor and I
do too so you raise the chickens and I'm
going to save my silver dollars and my
gold coins so I can buy some eggs from
you
all right let's see what do we got
Callum demek says you should talk about
the similarities between the Tennessee
legislature bringing back the Senators
uh they kicked out with the caning of
Senator some uh summer right before the
first American Civil War I.E hit him
again well I don't think it's the same
thing I mean the the pre-civil war
caning was merciless brutality which
left the guy permanently disabled
um depending on who you ask I suppose
and what we have now is a guy threw a
hot coffee was arrested for throwing hot
coffee uh three years four years ago and
then was permanently banned from the
capital later got elected as a Democrat
and brought into the capital then he
joined the protesters to storm the
capital so he got kicked out and then
got reinstated by democrats to go back
to the Capitol just recently so I
wouldn't call it a caning there are
similarities in that there's a division
between both sides but I don't know when
was the last time there was a an
expulsion in this matter it's been a
long time I'm pretty sure traffic can't
what is that probably traffic can't in
the U.S house when James trafficking
Congressman when was that
wow
what brought that about his story
congressman's traffic traffic hit story
is uh crazy yeah extraordinary is
absolutely wondered if you don't know
about that man I interviewed him I
interviewed him before and I'm still
shocked yeah what happened do you want
to take this Daniel
well you probably know the details
better than I do but it seems like he
was JFK too yeah big time I remember
going to the house floor for him yeah
you were the old you were everyone voted
no I mean everyone voted to expel
um lauderette voted not to expel and you
voted president because you objected to
the entire process it was ugly garbage
it was ugly
it's just like an emotional thing
people are trying what were they
throwing them out for uh uh they claimed
that he had some staffers paint his boat
but what they're really throwing him out
for is because he he showed that the
emperor had no clothes that the whole
system you know he was famous for going
down to the floor and give one minute
speeches that he ended with beam me up
Scotty you know and so he he had it's
really unique guy he had contempt and
disdain for all the hypocrisy in
Washington he never he never sat with
the Democrats no and he passed away from
an accident yeah
it depended yeah yeah I I you could see
my interview with him on we are change
maybe you'll be able to find it if you
look up James trafficant we are changed
but uh crazy story all right Ron well
Nogales says nice meeting you in person
thanks for taking a picture with me and
signed my book last February I had a
child's I had a child star who I'm a
huge fan of gave me the confidence I
need to meet you you're my hero and I
would have voted for you for president
in 2012. that's very nice
yeah
all right they theyetti says in 07 when
I was 17 and scared ishless by Alex
Jones's end game Dr Paul was the only
politician we were told we could trust I
supported his family only until Trump
still very grateful for Paul's
yeah I love Rand man you guys are so
different but it almost like freaks me
out that you're related I love it like I
want to see you together talking just
like yeah I think he does a very good
job and I'm pretty critical of myself so
sometimes I sit there and I said he's
better than I am that's just stuff here
he gives a good speech
he's very very knowledgeable on the
covet business the confrontation with
fauci is something for the history books
yeah uh here's a good one Anwar Abu
Baker says there's a Ron Paul Revolution
billboard still on the highway between
Nevada and California from Dr Paul's
last presidential campaign wow who sees
it when they're leaving California or
going to California yeah that's a good
question maybe when they're leaving and
then they can think about it maybe
they're leaving for a reason you know
or maybe they should see it before they
get there to be honest
turn around
all right what do we got here Phil H
says Libertarians have gained a lot of
ground with Republicans can the same be
done with Democrats or are they too far
gone
well my view is that Democrats believe
incorrect things too much there are
certainly conservatives who believe in
correct things but for the most part
when when I have a conversation with
somebody as it pertains to Ukraine or
economics or anything they're just like
I don't know
what they know is what the New York
Times just said last night
and that's probably why they don't like
coming on shows like this where we will
pull up all of the stories and they'll
have to confront those issues they don't
want to do it
so
all right
let's see
let's grab we'll grab a couple more
where we at
cornbop says Graf Ian Bud Light graphene
make the shirts Luke
I don't know I don't know if that one
will do well I don't know if Luke could
make a shirt for Ian a graphic insurance
but yeah I'll do it we'll donate it to
the graphene fund I don't understand the
the shirt that he's saying though
graphene Bud Light graphene
I don't know all right Trump says Ron's
superseding Ian in the 20 throws Luke
stopped throwing 20s
that's a dungeon your play Dungeons and
Dragons
have you played Dungeons and Dragons the
board game you rolled dice to do things
in the game and if you roll a 20 that
means you get a critical success so this
guy said you got more critical success
I'm not I'm not into those kind of games
you're not a gamer
I play I go to Congress instead yeah
play games yes all right kite the twin
blade says Dr Paul thank you for being
you you turned me from a rabid neocon in
2007 in into a right libertarian I found
real non-violent Solutions when none
were offered by the Republicans
I I completely agree I think that's
that's absolutely how uh at least a lot
of people I know felt
uh it is fascinating to hear now we have
Republicans come on the show and Luke
will say something like we've been
warning you about the FBI and the ATF
and the CIA the intelligence agencies
for a decade and then you'll get these
prominent conservatives going yeah you
were right the whole time we screwed up
and that's an amazing thing to say I
think it's great yeah who knew
destroying the Constitution was a bad
idea who knew destroying people's civil
liberties and freedom of speech in the
Fourth Amendment and and on and on and
on was a bad idea a lot of people saw
you warned people about 40 years ago
there's a video of you 40 years ago
warning about the FBI it's going viral
right now all over Twitter Glenn
Greenwald just tweeted it out uh but
I've been seeing that video for a very
long time you warning us about the FBI
and you were absolutely right on the
money and the situation we're in now is
just absurd for sure all right everybody
if you have not already would you kindly
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
if you think it's really good and head
over to timcast.com click join us to
become a member we're going to have a
members only uncensored show up in about
10 minutes on the front page where we'll
get into more cultural issues and some
medical components of cultural issues so
you won't want to miss it and we'll even
take calls from our members so again
timcast.com you can follow the show at
timcastirl on Instagram and I think
Facebook too you can follow me
personally at timcast Dr Paul and Daniel
do you guys want to shout anything out
just invite people to watch the Ron Paul
Liberty report we're live at Rumble noon
every Monday through Friday and the Ron
Paul Institute is ronpaulinstitute.org
is that noon Eastern uh that's noon
eastern time yes what's the rumble
Channel again what's the URL Ron Paul
Liberty report Daniel mcbaste and Dr now
thank you so much for for coming on the
show and talking about the not
aggression principle really appreciate
everything you guys have to do and
everything you guys are doing uh so
thank you so much if you guys want to
check out my channel it is youtube.com
forward slash we are change I do a lot
of videos there's many years of of a lot
of interviews interviews with Dr Paul
interviews with James traffickant a lot
of interesting people youtube.com we are
change and I'm doing an in real life
Meetup this Thursday 3 30 p.m Austin you
could find out about that by being a
member of Luke uncensored.com
luconsored.com see you there you said
Luke unfiltered yesterday there's two
websites okay I'm testing them out I'm
seeing which one works better
lucanfilter.com Lucan sensor.com both of
them work I'm Ian Crossland Ron anything
thanks for coming brother anything
you're thinking well I will just make a
point that I make frequently as a lot of
times after a speech or a meeting people
will come up and thank me for being a
big help and encouragement and what they
were doing but I have I have to admit
that I come for selfish reasons because
when I meet people like you who are
interested in what I'm in and you do you
know generally agreed with me that
that's an encouragement so I leave with
a positive attitude and that it's that I
benefit as much as you might tell me you
benefit so that that is what I think is
beneficial and the neat thing about all
this is is the home idea of the remn
that is so fascinating that I don't know
how long you've been on the air and all
but you probably have influenced a lot
of people and it sounds to me like gee I
sort of agree with those guys up there
they have a good message I wonder where
they got that
but it was Delight thanks for having me
here absolutely all right everybody we
uh surge is also pressing the buttons he
doesn't have a camera though but shout
out to Serge yeah I'm still here all
right we'll see you all over at
timcast.com in a few minutes thanks for
hanging out